this video is brought to you by
manscape.com the premier men's grooming
brand that offers the best tools and
solutions for men's hygiene across the
globe that's right manscaped has
officially taken over the world
hey 42 here if you're a fan of horror
movies you'll know there are certain
streets in this world
or any world for that matter that you
should avoid it all costs there's elm
streets home of the nightmare featuring
freddy krueger there's seven hills road
unhappy abode of damien the antichrist
in the omen ocean drive amityville is
the real life location of the house that
spawns the collective myths and legends
of the amityville horror and of course
you could choose just about any road in
care a lot hometown of the care bears
but a sinister street you're unlikely to
have heard of is boulevard running
through the quiet american town of
westfield new jersey
wide tree-lined and adorned with large
spacious homes
boulevard is the picture of
quintessential class america westfield
has been ranked in the top 100
wealthiest cities in the united states
and in 2014 the year our story begins it
ranked 30th in the list of the country's
safest towns
westfield was a haven for families with
means
and in the opinion of derek and maria
broadus it was the perfect place to
settle and raised their children derek
was from working-class stock in maine
and after working his way up through the
ranks of a major insurance firm in new
york he'd achieved a seniority and
salary that allowed his family to move
outside the big city for an idyllic
small town life they already lived in
another part of westfield but when the
house at 657 boulevard went on sale
they saw this as an opportunity to
secure their dream home
maria had grown up just around the
corner so when the couple successfully
bought the property for 1.3 million
dollars the entire transaction felt like
it was meant to be then again i think
everything you do feels like that when
you're splashing that kind of cash
however rather than a happily ever after
ending
their purchase marks the beginning of
what would be a five-year-long nightmare
as you know i've been a huge fan of
manscape for quite some time and they've
now gone global with the launch of their
new fourth generation electric body
trimmer that means international
shipping to the united states canada
australia the uk all of europe singapore
and south africa so now men all over the
world can experience the perfect tool
for your family jewels and get the
ultimate manscaped experience when they
purchased their new performance package
4.0 bundle first stop on manscape's
intergalactic takeover is the lawnmower
4.0 waterproof cordless body trimmer it
even has a built-in led light to help
you trim with confidence
even in your black hole if you know what
i mean inspired by the engineers over at
nasa the manscape team redesigns the new
lawnmower 4.0 to include a nifty cool
new wireless charging system
also listed in the launch plan is the
crop preserver ball deodorant and crop
reviver ball toner spray these are
perfect for your little asteroids whilst
you're orbiting the sun throughout your
day but manscaped is so much more than a
ball trimmer company in fact the new
performance package 4.0 bundle now
includes their new weed whacker nose and
ear hair trimmer and now for a limited
time you can also get not one but two
free gifts the shared travel bag and the
manscaped anti-chafing high-performance
boxer briefs all you need to do is head
to manscapes.com
forward slash 42 today to get 20 off
free international shipping plus two
free gifts join the two million men
worldwide who trust manscaped and get
your rocket ready for takeoff
your balls and your body
will thank you
just three days after buying 657
boulevard derek was at the house working
on renovations that needed to be
finished before his family could move in
going through the mailbox that night he
found an envelope addressed in thick
chunky handwriting to
the new owner
it started innocently enough
dearest new neighbor at 657 boulevard
allow me to welcome you to the
neighborhood but then it took an
increasingly sinister tone
with the author describing himself as
the custodian of the house
657 boulevard has been the subject of my
family for decades now
and as it approaches its 110th birthday
i have been put in charge of watching
and waiting for its second coming
my grandfather watched a house in the
1920s
and my father watched it in the 1960s
it is now my time
do you know the history of the house do
you know what lies within the walls of
657 boulevard
why are you here
i will find out
most people would probably shrug this
off as some neighborhood weirdo playing
a prank
but then
it got personal
the writer had clearly been studying the
house and the broadest family he spoke
about their honda minivan as well as the
workers renovating the property most
ominously he specifically mentioned the
broadest children who were five eight
and ten at the time
you have children
i have seen them so far i think there
are three that i have counted do you
need to fill the house with the young
blood i requested
better for me was your old house too
small for the growing family or was it
greed to bring me your children
once i know their names i will call to
them and draw them to me who am i the
person wrote
there are hundreds and hundreds of cars
that drive by 657 boulevard each day
maybe i am in one look at all the
windows you can see from 657 boulevard
maybe i am in one look out any of the
many windows in 657 boulevard it's all
the people who stroll by each day
maybe i am one the typed letter ended
with one final salutation welcome my
friends welcome let the party begin
before being signed off as
the watcher
by now derek was well and truly freaked
out alone in the house he ran around
turning off lights before calling the
police before speeding home to his
family he and maria typed an email to
john and andrea woods the couple who'd
sold them the house asking if they had
any knowledge of the watcher or
why the writer had said i asked the
woods to bring me young blood and it
looks like they listened the woods had
lived at 657 boulevard for 23 years
and when they replied to the email the
next day they said that nothing unusual
had ever happened until just a few days
before they moved out
when they had also received a letter
from the watcher but andrea thought it
was just odd and threw it away
nevertheless the woods accompanied the
broadest to the police station where the
lead detective instructed them not to
tell anyone about the letter as everyone
in the neighborhood was a suspect two
weeks later maria broader stopped by the
house to check on the painting and clear
the mail
when she found another envelope with the
same thick black lettering of the
watcher
this time the delivery was addressed
directly to derek and maria even though
their surname was misspelt the mystery
voyeur had a lot of new information to
share he knew the children's nicknames
as well as their birth order
especially harrowing he described how
one of the children had used an easel
inside the enclosed porch asking
is she the artist of the family then
things took a turn from
right so there's a creep in the
neighborhood to
holy crap we've literally moved to elm
street 657 boulevard is anxious for you
to move in it has been years and years
since the young blood ruled the hallways
of the house
have you found all of the secrets it
holds yet
will the young blood play in the
basement or are they too afraid to go
down there alone
i would be very afraid if i were them it
is far away from the rest of the house
if you were upstairs you would never
hear them scream
yeah that's just about the point where
i'd seriously consider myself
will they sleep in the attic or will you
all sleep on the second floor
who has the bedrooms facing the street
i'll know as soon as you move in it will
help me to know who is in which bedroom
then i can plan better understandably
derek and maria stopped bringing their
children to the house and now began to
reconsider moving in altogether
a few weeks later another letter arrived
where have you gone to it read
657 boulevard is missing you by now the
borders were at their wits end they were
reluctant to move in until the watcher
had been identified
but their previous house was sold so
they had to move in with maria's parents
at the same time though they had to
continue paying the mortgage property
taxes and maintenance costs on 657
boulevard adding financial strain to an
already stressed situation
derek started to lapse into depression
whilst maria was diagnosed with
post-traumatic stress disorder
eventually
six months after receiving the first
letter the broader sis gave up and
decided to put the house back on the
market unsurprisingly there wasn't
exactly a bidding war for the property
to cover the renovation work derek and
maria initially listed the house for
more than they paid for it
but despite their commitment to keeping
the watcher under wraps rumors had begun
to circulate
that something was not quite right about
the house
offers came in well below asking price
and when the broadest is disclosed to
serious buyers why they were selling
those offers were retracted the broadest
has begun to wonder how they would have
reacted if they'd been told about the
watcher before buying the house
and concluded that the previous owners
probably should have notified them of
the creepy letter they'd received
shortly before moving out
so in june 2015 a year after moving in
derek and maria broadus filed a legal
complaint against john and andrea woods
for their failure to disclose
disinformation about the watchers letter
despite the woods is insisting from the
start that the letter they'd received
had been strange rather than threatening
the watcher had even thanked them for
taking care of the house
the broadest legal action not only
failed it backfired a local reporter had
discovered the complaint and read the
snippets from the watch's letters
that had been included in the legal
files so the story blew up and went
viral soon the house was surrounded by
reporters and any hopes derek and maria
had of keeping the story quiet and
shielding their kids from the drama
were dashed
the watcher of 657 boulevard became the
fodder of social media and online forums
with hundreds of different theories
about his identity meanwhile official
investigations to uncover that identity
were underway after the second letter
was sent derek brodus had shown the
police detective how the easel in the
covered porch was obscured from the
street by bushes the only house that had
a clear view of the easel and could have
watched derek's daughter painting
was the house of the langfords a family
who lived directly next door peggy
langford was in her 90s and several of
her children all in their 60s lived with
her michael langford was one of those
children
and was known in the neighborhood for
his odd behavior he had schizophrenia
when he was younger and would sometimes
wander through people's gardens
staring in through their windows
but everyone in the area fought him
harmless
of course everyone said that about ted
bundy too
so it wasn't long before michael
langford became the prime suspect and
was brought in for questioning
he denied knowing anything about the
letters and because there was nothing
tying him to the case
the police had to let him go by the end
of 2014 the police investigation had
dried up without any idea of who the
watcher might be
by now derek had become obsessed with
the case installing webcams and lying in
the dark of the night to see if anyone
was watching the house from nearby
he employed a private investigator and
made contact with two ex-fbi agents
one of whom happened to be the
inspiration for the character of clarice
stalling in silence of the lambs but all
the extra effort and support came to
nothing
michael langford was still the chief
suspect so
the lead detective suggested that the
brothers should secretly write a letter
to the langfords
pretending as neighbors to notify them
of their intentions to tear the house
down the hope was that it would spark a
response from the watcher
thereby confirming that one of the
langfords was behind the letters
but no such response came
and according to the police the case had
run cold when the story became public
knowledge in mid-2015
the national media attention revealed
that the original police work had been
sloppy to say the least
so a veteran detective baron shambles
was asked to look at the case
he discovered that earlier on in the
investigation dna had actually been
gathered from one of the letters and
that the dna was revealed to be female
soon abby langford michael langford's
sister was a suspect
her motive
she was a real estate agent and had lost
out on the sale of 657 boulevard so
perhaps the letters were part of a
revenge play
but when abby's dna was sneakily poached
from a water bottle she'd been drinking
from
it was found to be different from the
dna on the letters soon after the
prosecutor's office informs derek and
maria that the langfords were no longer
suspects
end of story
in the months that followed there were
multiple leads that came to nothing
on a stakeout one night detective
chambliss saw a car stop outside 657
for an unusually long time
he traced a number plate to a girl from
a neighboring town whose boyfriend lived
on the same block as 657 she told police
that he was into some really dark
computer games including one in which he
played a character called the watcher
when he was called in for questioning
the boyfriend twice agreed to attend
but twice failed to show up
and since he couldn't legally be
compelled to submit to questioning
nothing further happened on another
occasion the painter working at 657
boulevard saw strange behavior at the
house directly behind
the couple who'd lived there for 47
years had a pair of lawn chairs
stationed at the edge of their property
facing the broadest home
on one afternoon the painter saw the
elderly neighbor sitting on the lawn
chair watching the house
it later turned out that one of the
elderly couple's children had married a
man who'd grown up in 657 boulevard this
was especially eerie because in one of
the letters the watcher had written the
house cries for the past and what used
to be in the time when i roamed its
halls despite how peculiar the
neighbor's behavior was
it also led to nothing personally i'd
advise avoiding this entire street never
mind just six five seven
everyone seems to be a bloody case
after a while with no one else left to
blame the light of suspicion was shone
on the broadests themselves locals began
to question how in the space of a few
short years the family had jumped from a
300 000
house to a 700 000 house then
to a 1.3 million dollar house theories
began to fly that the entire drama was
an elaborate ploy by the broadest is to
get out of a purchase that they could
never actually afford others guessed
that derek was concocting some form of
insurance fraud yet another suggestion
was that they'd planned the whole thing
to get media attention and a movie deal
which if true has worked out quite well
since netflix will soon be covering this
story naturally there is no evidence to
any of these claims but they did serve
to alienate the broadest family from the
community in the spring of 2016 derek
and maria put 657 back on the market
hoping they would get more interest than
previously
but they were ultimately disappointed
eventually in desperation they applied
to have the plot subdivided hoping to
sell the property to a developer who
could build two homes on it however the
town planning board rejected the
application on grounds at each of the
subdivided properties would be less than
four feet narrower than regulations
required when the broadest has appealed
this tea was rejected despite the fact
the planning board granted permission
for a similar subdivision just around
the corner a short while later perhaps
the watcher was a member of the board by
this stage the broadests were
hemorrhaging cash for almost three years
they'd been paying a fortune for a house
they couldn't live in then they finally
received some good news
a renter had agreed to move into 657 and
even though he said he wasn't worried
about the watcher his tenancy agreement
included a get out clause in case
another letter arrived two weeks later
that's exactly what happened more than
two and a half years had passed since
the watcher's first letter and the note
was filled with anger and threats of
revenge it recounted all the steps derek
and maria had taken to try to get rid of
the house and celebrated the many local
residents who'd stood up during the
planning board meeting to oppose the
broadest application to tear down the
house and subdivide their property the
watcher even mocked derek's nighttime
vigils at the house saying
i watched as you watched from the dark
house in an attempt to find me
telescopes and binoculars are wonderful
inventions despite the letter the renter
agreed to stay on and the broadest is
went on with trying to rebuild their
life elsewhere things did take a strange
turn in december 2017
when
on christmas eve the people who'd been
most outspoken and critical of the
producers online
received typed letters in their
mailboxes written in a strangely poetic
style
very similar to the watchers the letters
accused the receivers of unfairly
tarring the broadests and told stories
of domestic terrorism that had taken
place because someone with simmering
mental illness had been left untreated
the cards were signed friends of the
broadest family a year later derek
broadus admitted he had delivered the
cards in an expression of anger and
frustration but he maintained that these
were the first letters he'd ever sent
the broadest family finally got some
closure on this ordeal in july 2019 when
they sold the house at 657 boulevard for
960 000
though they could finally leave the
house behind them it had cost them five
years of pain and hundreds of thousands
of dollars for a home they never spent
one night in as a family in his final
letter the watcher had written
you are despised by the house
and the watcher one with no one ever
held accountable and a family
traumatized for half a decade
it seems he may have been right
thanks for watching do you really enjoy
my content but you literally can't be
asked to use your eyes
then you're in luck because you can now
listen to the new random interesting
facts podcast with me 42 available on
youtube spotify apple podcast or
wherever you get your podcast you'll
find a link to it in the description
below check it out today and give your
eyes a break you're welcome